er Bischof stehplan Herr Mecke sagt
gerade nicht über jede Waffenart neu
diskutieren das ist nicht die Debatte
die uns vorantreibt sie haben sich
eingebracht in diese Debatte und haben
auch ganz offensiv für Waffenlieferung
plädiert im Zusammenhang mit der
Diskussion und panzerlieferung wie
erklären sie das innerhalb der Kirche
wie erklären sie das innerhalb der
Gemeinde und vor allen Dingen was ist
das Ziel für Sie von diesen
Panzerlieferungen also ich will mal das
Wort offensiv ausmalen indem ich sage
mit dem Hinweis auf die große
Zerrissenheit die das für jeden Christen
Menschen bedeuten muss wenn ich für
Waffenlieferungen eintreten das ist ja
nichts was wir so leicht hin machen
sondern was wir mit großen Schmerzen
machen und immer auch mit Blick auf die
Frieden sehen sucht die wir zu
verkündigen haben und die das erste ist
was aus der Bibel herausspricht
sein und an dem Punkt möchte ich dann
aber bleiben weil er interessant ist
gibt es für sie als geistlichen gute
Waffen schlechte Waffen nein es gibt
nicht ein guter schlechte offen es gibt
Waffen die Menschen in diesem Moment
brauchen um sich und ihr Land vor einem
völkerrechtswidrigen schrecklichen
brutalen Angriff zu verteidigen und
darum geht auch an dieser auf der einen
Seite Waffen gesegnet werden auf der
ukrainischen Seite auf der anderen Seite
auf der russischen Seite im mindestens
ganz genauso von den Kreml anhängenden
geistlichen dort Waffen gesegnet werden
Soldaten gesegnet werden überhaupt keine
Waffen mehr und kann es an dieser Stelle
nicht gehen und darf es auch nicht bin
in sehr dankbar dass sie dann noch mal
nachfragen es geht auch bei dem Werben
darum dass ich ein Verständnis für diese
Position der Regierung unseres Landes an
der Stelle haben niemals darum dass ich
jetzt offensiv mit einem hurra in diesem
Krieg möchte das ist uns alles total
fern sondern es geht in dieser
schrecklichen Situation als erstes darum
und das ist dann auch meine theologische
und christliche Begründung Menschen die
angegriffen werden beizuschauen und so
wie ich als Christ
gerade auch in der Ethik des ich muss
Unrecht erleiden für mich sprechen kann
so darf ich eben niemals das für andere
verordnen ich kann nicht dem anderen
sagen du musst das Unrecht einfach
hinnehmen und darfst dich nicht
verteidigen und genau darum geht es bei
dieser Frage in einer Situation die für
uns alle schrecklich ist zu sagen dann
müssen auch Waffen möglich sein und dann
haben wir ja am Anfang des Krieges diese
Unterscheidung zwischen den
verteidigungs- und den Angriffswaffen
gehabt jetzt wird immer deutlicher dass
ich sozusagen diese Trennlinie nicht
scharf ziehen kann wenn ich die Ukraine
nicht ihrem Schicksal des angegriffen
Seins einfach überlassen will aber ich
muss immer in dieser theologisch
christlichen ethisch klaren
Positionierung bleiben und darf nicht in
einen Triumph fallen ihre Antwort zeigt
die Zerrissenheit und zeigt auch dass es
sie natürlich auch fühlt als geistiger
als jemand der vor der Gemeinde steht
das auch erklärt und mit sich bring das
spürt man in dieser an dieser Antwort
und letztlich haben all diese Waffen die
solidarisch ein solidarisches Zeichen
setzen die zur Verteidigung dienen
sollen auch
das ist völlig klar in dieser
schrecklichen Situation gibt es eben
keine Alternative aber das möchte ich
dann in dieser Runde auch einmal sagen
natürlich muss unsere Anstrengung und
das hört man ja hier auch bei allen
Beteiligten wieder dahin gehen zu gucken
welche Lösung gibt es denn dann am Ende
jedenfall und damit meine ich jetzt
nicht explizit nur die deutsche die
kleine Kirche sondern die großen die
katholische Kirche die große
protestantische Kirche zu wenig ein nein
das glaube ich nicht wir hatten ja auch
ähm den die ökumenische Konferenz in
Karlsruhe im letzten Jahr große
Auseinandersetzung ich glaube wir sind
da z.B nach Moskau weil ich glaube
zunächst einmal sind wir auch in der
Pflicht auf die Orte doxe russische
Kirche einzuwirken dass sie endlich
aufhört diesen Krieg diesen Krieg Putin
zu warum sie daran glauben Sie daran
putin ist ganz eng mit dem höchsten
seitlichen mit Kyrill glauben Sie
ernsthaft darin wäre es eine Möglichkeit
dass der Papst nach Moskau fährt also
diese Möglichkeit will ich nicht
ausschließen aber ich glaube im Moment
geht es ja noch nicht um solche
zeichenhandlungen die müssen auch im
richtigen Moment Erfolgen im Moment geht
es darum dass wir auch in der großen
Christengemeinschaft in der Ökumene uns
gegenseitig so stärken dass etwa die
Position Kyrills als das geächtet wird
was sie ist eine kriegstreibende
Position die wir aus christlicher
Perspektive ganz klar ablegen müssen
bleiben arbeitet und in der Kirche
arbeitet so mag es auch in ihnen
gearbeitet haben in den vergangenen
Monaten und immer noch arbeiten sie
haben einzeln Kriegsdienst verweigert
das habe ich gesagt auch in der DDR Zeit
damals bei der Nationalen Volksarmee was
hat das war noch ein bisschen anders als
in Berlins im Westen zu verweigern was
hat das für sie damals bedeutet
das war sehr klares Bekenntnis damals
für mich durchaus auch pazifistisch also
ich habe geglaubt dass man als Christ
keine Waffe in die Hand nehmen muss sie
haben Nachteile dadurch
hätte weil ich hatte auch total
verweigert habe da standen zwei Jahre
Gefängnis drauf das heißt das hätte
passieren können ist dann nicht passiert
das konnte man aber vorher natürlich
nicht wissen aber für mich waren auch
diese Begründung ich habe die später
wieder gefunden in den einzelnen Punkten
dass ich sage einerseits war es ein
partizipistisch ist dann gab es auch
politisch gesagt Deutschland ist zweimal
im Krieg begonnen hat darf es nicht tun
und das dritte war das die beiden
deutschen Staaten meine gesamte Familie
lebt im Western gesagt die richten nicht
die Waffen gegen aufeinander und ich
habe mal habe dann ja später
im Bundestag die Auslandseinsätze
befürwortet weil ich der festen
Überzeugung bin
dass so wie es Polizei im
innerstaatlichen gibt die natürlich auch
Gewalt anwenden muss gegen Verbrecher
dass dies auch international geht aber
es geht immer um die Stützung und die
Förderung und die Etablierung des Rechts
sie haben und das ist dann auch die
Aufgabe natürlich immer sehr begrenzt
aber wo notwendig dann eben auch
wirklich mit voller Unterstützung
Teil dieser Erklärung damals ihrer
Begründung zur Kriegsdienstverweigerung
auch veröffentlicht transparent gemacht
sie haben damals geschrieben so sagen
sie ich möchte damit einen
Friedensdienst leisten der mir als der
einzig mögliche und für mich gangbare
erscheint es muss Menschen geben die
anfangen deutlich zu machen dass in der
Zukunft ein Weg der Gewaltlosigkeit und
der Liebe zum Mitmenschen eingeschlagen
werden muss haben sie diesen Glauben
zumindest in jedem Fall diesen Glauben
an die Gewaltlosigkeit verloren
also ich habe glaube nicht dass dies in
jeder Situation gilt das gilt übrigens
auch wir hatten jetzt gerade oder wir
haben dann die friedliche Revolution die
ja oft dann als Argument benutzt wird
und übrigens auch innerhalb der Kirche
wie ich weiß als Argument benutzt wird
etwa von dem friedensbeauftragten wo ich
anderer Meinung bin wo ich sage dies ist
kein Modell
wir brauchen
Gewalt um Recht zu halten um da wo ein
Gewalttäter es bricht und dann eben
nicht nur also einer den Opfern
beizustehen aber auch das Rechte zu
erhalten und das ist eine ganz zentrale
Dimension zu der ich mich bekenne und
insofern habe ich natürlich auch einen
Weg
der Veränderung bin ich gegangen auch
Erfolg ist diesen gegangen auch sie
haben den Kriegsdienst verweigert über
eine andere Vergangenheit die hat ja nie
darüber ihn gerade schon angesprochen
mit Kommunisten eine kommunistisches
Gedankengut sie haben sich sehr weit
verändert herr Fuchs wir haben heute
eben das haben wir in dieser Anwendung
auch gehört massiv eben für weitere
Waffenlieferungen warum
für mich war der Boss im Krieg
sein ein politischer Wendepunkt dass ich
kommt tatsächlich aus einer
antibilitaristischen sagen Tradition die
würde ich für mich auch weiter
reklamieren übrigens auch das Prinzip
Gewaltfreiheit in
innergesellschaftlichen
Auseinandersetzungen ja ich bin ein
absoluter Befürworter
des des Gewaltverzichts als Mittel der
politischen Auseinandersetzung
Gewaltfreiheit ist ein ein hohes Gut was
Zivilität in der politischen
Auseinandersetzung erst
gewährleistet aber wir mussten erleben
übrigens nicht erst in der 90er Jahren
ich meine Deutschland das Deutsche Reich
musste in einem
furchtbaren Krieg niedergerungen werden
Europa und auch Deutschland ist
militärisch befreit worden dass dann
eine Lektion die man nicht einfach
vergessen kann ja und nie wieder Krieg
das bedeutet nie wieder Angriffskrieg
von deutschen Boden aus es gibt aber
noch das zweite nie wieder Völkermord
und das war Bosnien ja das Anfang der
90er Jahren Europa ein Krieg begonnen
wurde bis dahin waren sie ihre
Begründung Folgen zu naiv ja ich würde
sagen habe glaube ich unterschätzt diese
Rückkehr der Gewalt als Mittel der
Politik und um es mal theologisch zu
formulieren die Rückkehr des Bösen in
die Politik es gibt
Mächte des Bösen den man nur mit
Entschiedenheit begegnen kann würden Sie
heute noch den werdenden verweigern vor
diesem Hintergrund nein sie würden zum
Bund gehen ist jetzt sehr hypothetisch
aber wenn sie noch nicht
heute eine demokratische Armee dem
stimme ich zu wobei ich politisch heute
für eine allgemeine Dienstpflicht bin
das heißt mit der Wahlfreiheit für in
verschiedene Bereiche zu gehen um das
geweint wohl zu stärken und das halte
ich für zentral dass wir diese Weg gehen
zur Waffe greifen sie würden unser Land
verteidigen
ich würde in einer spezifischen
Situation ich würde diesmal auch sagen
wenn ich auch jünger wäre auch ich würde
in die Ukraine gehen sie würden ihre
Kinder ihre Enkelkinder dorthin schicken
nein ich würde niemanden schicken ich
habe gesagt ich würde gehen weil ich das
Gefühl habe dass das ein ganz
entscheidender Auseinandersetzung für
die Zukunft Europas ist in niederlinie
sie haben ja vor allen Dingen über die
Jüngeren gesprochen haben gesagt viele
die früher ganz stark eine Generation
die ganz stark für den Frieden war ganz
stark passivistisch unterwegs war die
sei mittlerweile er hat belizistisch
geprägt wie die klassisch also
kriegsverherrlichend auch hat sich eine
solche Kriegsverherrlichung ihrer
Meinung breit gemacht ja also
Kriegsverherrlichung
wie bezeichnen wir das ja die einen sind
der Meinung wir müssen alles tun damit
möglichst bald ein Waffenstillstand oder
Friedensverhandlungen aufgenommen werden
übrigens Kollege hat das vor Weihnachten
gefordert er hat nicht in
Waffenstillstand gefordert aber hat
gefordert eine internationale Konferenz
einzuberufen die auslotet welche
friedenschancen ist gibt also damit man
der Legende dass die Ukraine
grundsätzlich immer schon gegen jede
Form von Friedensverhandlungen hat ja
auch im Gegenteil sie hat verhandelt da
gibt's ja berühmte Beispiele die ein
bisschen umstritten sind in der
Interpretation
also lass mal diese Begriffe beiseite
aber es gibt eine auffälligen Schnitt
gewissermaßen in der Bevölkerung das ist
schon
erklärungsbedürftig dass eine Generation
von Kriegsdienst verweigeren sage ich
jetzt mal auf einmal doch sehr massiv
sagt wir müssen mit Waffen rein schon
vorher hieß es noch erinnern Sie sich
bärbock hat Habeck zurückgepfiffen im
Wahlkampf als Harbeck gesagt hat wir
werden nicht umhin kommen das war noch
vor Beginn des Krieges
Verteidigungswaffen an die Ukraine zu
liefern da sagte Berber kommt auf keinen
Fall in Frage ja gut und jetzt überlege
ich mir manchmal das ist eine längere
Geschichte ich war am Anfang auch ein
bisschen irritiert über diese dieses
Phänomen das so viele die vorher ganz in
meinen Augen ganz zu Unrecht übrigens
der Meinung war unter keinen Bedingungen
die Kurden Hofreiter dürfen nicht
unterstützt werden die Kurden die
einzigen halbwegs vernünftigen in dem
Syrien Konflikt dürfen nicht unterstützt
werden mit Waffen und so weiter und so
weiter dass dieselben auf einmal so um
switchen in ihrer Orientierung und das
hat mich beschäftigt da könnten das
länger drüber reden und eine Erklärung
scheint mir folgende zu sein
auch gar keine Kritik was ganz normal
wir wachsen in bestimmten Zeiten auf wer
nach 1990 darunter ist hier niemand ja
auch nicht siehe jünger sind als ich
werden erst nach 1990 politisch
sozialisiert wurde
hatte eine Welt vor sich bei der
jedenfalls den Eindruck hatte der Westen
der kann die Dinge in Ordnung bringen es
gab auch massive Unterstützung für
sogenannte humanitäre Interventionen und
so weiter der Westen kann doch wenn er
will
und die Älteren die haben noch in
Erinnerung als Kind Kubakrise wie meine
Eltern dann auf einmal Reis gekauft
haben oder dann 83 noch mal beinahe
dritter Weltkrieg da steckt uns
gewissermaßen in den Knochen und auch
die Versuche mit einer stalinistischen
üblen Diktatur spätzstalistisch dann in
irgendeiner Weise zu einem Ausgleich zu
kommen und die sagen sich moment mal
jetzt dürfen wir nicht auf einmal
leichtsinnig werden und ich setze hinzu
vielleicht ein bisschen realistischer
das Spiel ist aus der Westen hatte die
Chance viel zu gestalten die New World
Order von Busch Senior war nicht so
völlig absurd nach 1990 das wird der
frühere Außenminister vielleicht
bestätigen ja der das wurde der letzten
frei gewählten DDR Regierung
unterlautern
neudeutsch heißt das wurde im Grunde
nicht genutzt mit zum Teil absurden
Interventionen die alle schief gegangen
sind Afghanistan und so weiter Moment
und jetzt ist die Vorstellung die ja
jetzt haben wir hier in der Ukraine
natürlich einen Kriegs ist in der Tat
vor der Haustür das kann auf keinen Fall
sein übrigens will nur mal festhalten
wir waren uns alle einig dass die
Ukraine unterstützt werden musste damit
sie sich verteidigen kann gegen den
Greifer waren wir hier diese auch mal
schön eine Einigkeit feststellen Frage
ist nur wie geht's jetzt weiter
und ich glaube wir müssen lernen dass
wir eine extrem instabile Weltlage haben
dass wir drei Weltmächte haben mit der
einen Welt macht verbinde ganz viel mit
der USA Demokratie transatlantisches
Bündnis Menschenrechte aber alle drei
Weltmächte sind unzufrieden mit dem
Status Quo gewesen in den letzten
Jahrzehnten sie haben Chancen genutzt
das zu verändern der spätankömmling
china macht das ganz massiv mit massiver
Aufrüstung gegenwärtig Russland reagiert
mit einem regionalen Imperialismus
sozusagen in seiner Region mit
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskriegen das
ist hoch gefährlich ja und in dieser
Situation erinnert man sich
gewissermaßen an die mühsamen Schritte
die dazu geführt haben dass wir so viele
Jahrzehnte nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
eine Friedenszeit hatten und über die
Schritte raus über mögliche Schritte
raus aus diesem Konflikt über unseren
Plan hier an diesem Tisch für diesen
Krieg raus aus diesen Krieg sprechen wir
gleich nach einer ganz kurz raus ist
wurden sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen Dank
Bild kämpft für Sie